Flash Forward I go and do the Simpsons
and then and it's too hard to explain
but all these crazy things happen it's
really the equivalent of me being in a
cornfield and getting hit by a meteor
but all these things happen where
suddenly um they say hey you're you're
going to uh we replace David Letterman
the guy you idolize who I said many
times cannot be replaced I said there's
it's impossible to replace him so I pity
the guy who replaces him I'm on record
saying that and I salivating to replace
him we had totally different dreams
because he was hired to produce the show
yeah but his dream was not that like you
say you did happy happy good show and
you were always the funniest guy in the
room at SNL and I was more like you know
Broody Tom jovic you know just brooding
brooding writer right uh but but my
dream was like to like my hero was like
Sylvester Pat Weaver the guy who created
The Today Show and The Tonight Show I
love the IDE the saddest thing I've ever
heard anybody say I was a pathetic nerd
Blair poster of of Pat Weaver I do I do
understand he understands I no I would
go to the museum of broadcasting or
whatever radio and television and revel
in these old like Dave gay talking to a
chimp on the Today's Show in the 50s and
no you were ready to I mean but what was
interesting is so they came they said to
me okay you're going to do this and I
said it then I say it now I said I can
do this if I do it with Robert yeah yeah
I said I can do this if I do it with
Robert Smigel but it it I can't do it if
it's not with Robert smel and um I don't
think I ever heard that I know you said
you told me you wanted me to do it I
know I didn't tell you I wanted you to
do it I said you have to do it and then
I remembered there was stuff about well
Robert's contract we're not sure and I
was Lauren just didn't want me to leave
no I know but I was yelling at
NBC give him every you know like give
him take stuff from me and give a take
like we have to do this together because
I knew then I had a shot and uh and um
and it's true and uh we um don't get
self-conscious because I'm complimenting
you take the paper away that's my
job but anyway uh and then um
immediately we had very little time to
put the show together I mean it stuns me
now that I think by the time by the time
I was done doing the affiliate dance and
everything I think it was June and the
had to be on the air in September
September 13th of 1993 it's June and
there's just a big empty space where
Dave Studio was and we had no writers we
had nothing right but I knew Robert and
I will just start we go and we worked
our at we didn't sleep we worked like
crazy all summer long it was the best it
was so is my dream job and I was working
with you I I was just like the best guy
I could work with and I have to confess
when he first told me and you know this
you remember the conversation I'm sure
when you first told me Lauren wants me
to audition there was a part of me that
was like scared yeah like I hey guess
what me too but but I I remember this
very clearly you were like gee I don't
know because if hard that's a hard way
to break into show business that's what
I said if you if you if you you know
it's going to be hard for anybody I mean
the only person it wouldn't have been
hard for is I think Gary Shandling Gary
Shandling was a name they were Bing on
and if he had done it it been absolutely
brilliant from day one cuz he's Gary
Shandling but everyone else would have
taken some knocks for not being Dave um
but I was going to take a lot of knocks
because complete unknown and no
experience and um I remember so clearly
I remember where I was I was living in
this little apartment on
Weatherly and I had in this tiny little
Nook I had a phone and a phone machine
back when you had a phone machine and
I'm talking to you and you're sort of
saying I'm saying yeah they they're
thinking maybe I should audition because
they they're looking for the right
person and Lauren said you know he's got
a look and maybe and look and he's very
polite and he's got the hair the funny
first name and it maybe that's a thing
and so um and he'll be cheap and he'll
oh trust
me you'll get him for nothing and so my
salary
non-negotiable and just because I'm
saying you're going to save money on
him not
me so I remember talking to you and you
were rightly I was shum you were you
were shbl you were saying yeah I don't
know I don't know I don't and then in
the background I heard like a Charlie
Brown uh parent voice
go and I said what was that and you said
well that was Michelle yeah because you
know your wife and I and I and not wife
at the time girlfriend at the time I
think and you said and you said um and
she
said and I said what's she saying and
she saying uh and and you said Michelle
said he's got nothing to lose right and
then you said huh I think that's kind of
true like why not what I mean and then
of course I thought yeah I guess I could
be a national joke but that that was the
fear the first year the fear was the
first year was who's the famous National
joke I have to say also that like so
then I did hesitate a tiny bit and I
then I just like it was like a few hours
I was like wow man I don't know man if
he can do it I just he's never been on
TV and and then I just thought to myself
so like you know we both love performing
and I got to do a few things on Weekend
Update I did and Conan was already with
The Simpsons and I just remembered like
this guy helped me for hours with my
stupid Weekend Update feature
perspective and I'm like I'm I'm
hesitating it's the and
I called you back and I was like yeah
yeah I mean this is my buddy but then I
I had uh we had I never once celebrated
like I end up I audition they think
about it and then they give it to me and
and never I was always scared and always
filled with the sense of responsibility
and here it is now over 30 years later
yeah and I have never once I don't think
I celebrate anything I mean I I don't
but I just was always like well we'll
see we'll see and still now I'm 60 and
I'm going we'll see boy we'll see if we
see how what happens but uh but I think
it was appropriate not to celebrate
getting that show because it was it was
not like getting cast in an amazing role
it it felt to me in a very Catholic way
like this is a test and you're going to
have to walk through hell and then
that's what happened that is what
happened but but I remember so then he
had that audition which was incredible I
mean I guess it was and then I asked him
about it and he said well I had nothing
to lose and and he was like in front of
I don't know how many people were in
that room I I don't know there was it
was a tiny no it was a it was a good
size I don't
people yeah and he interviewed Jason
Alexander and Mimi Rogers and his Mimi
Rogers interview was just like
professional hysterical and then I just
turned on a dime I was like this guy's
gonna be enormous and and then he was so
funny and hilarious when we assembled
writers we all got incredibly
overconfidence yes we're like
everybody's going to have a
long skinny pants I I was positive and
so but every everyone's going to be one
I have kind of like ambivalent ambiguous
gender uh I it was a good kind of a guy
but also a little bit of a girl no but
for his he stayed nervous but the rest
of us were so confident and it was great
because it made us try everything we
were Fearless we tried every idea and
obviously some went to but still
the proudest achievement of my whole
career easily is how much stuff we did
generate if you look at the first two
years that's the thing that I'm stunned
well even if you work at the first three
weeks there's so much material that you
did Forever on The Late Night show we
did the Clutch Cargo in the year 2000
the actual items there's so many things
that but then we
kept we never stopped trying to uh try
new things and and um I remember people
used to uh who were in the business
would say I mean I remember even David
Letterman saying that's insane because
we would we were basically trying to do
Saturday Night Live every night yes
which is which is impossible and then
finally you could smell the smoke of
like the gears grinding yes people going
insane no one's sleeping it's funny
because like so many I think I've told
you this story so like in 19 and it was
a lot of it stemmed from people on the
staff who just didn't believe in us some
PE a lot some people really believed you
know like Frank back there and Paula and
um but then uh you know like so in 1999
or 90 or 2009 I visited the Fallon set
and yeah because back then when we did
it people were like every night live
we're doing over here and I visited the
Fallon set and everybody was like all
perky and happy and they were doing
really ambitious when he first
started in late 0 they were doing all
these detailed film pieces and literally
crew members said to me it's like every
night
live